hello everyone and welcome to another
video on code tech and tutorials now
this is going to be a vlog style video
and I've decided to do this okay
well you know by the title what there's
already sort of is this is something
I've been working on that's been near
and dear to my heart for all of 2019 and
some of 2018 and you know I'm really
into reality and getting to the root of
things and I think it's good for people
to address things as they are so that's
kind of what this is about this engine
is that good news is that bad news well
it's actually great news it's excellent
news especially for all of you out there
because I'm actually gonna show
something well I'm not trying to okay
I'll just get to it I'm not trying to
say that this is some revolutionary
thing because it's simply not other
people have done it better I am just a
guy that's learning to program and
working on game development working on
my own game engine and finding out it is
extremely I want to say challenging and
that's true it's challenging but it's
also encompassing and I don't know if
that's the right word for it but there's
just a lot there's so much to do it's
nuts so I want to go through all these
old branches and old iterations and just
show what the engine was like in the
past and some of these are going to be
terrible
and that's kind of the point so here's
all the branches and what I want to say
about these is these go in iterations so
I had this idea that I was going to
knock out some games and I talked to a
knock out building some games with my
engine and I talked to a few friends and
they were sort of an but they didn't
really know how to help to me because
this is all kind of my thing and well
they did help some especially with
keeping me motivated more than anything
and yeah I just kind of want to show I
show where they are and I don't want to
throw them under the bus because these
are really my creations so any flack
they get for being as epically terrible
as they might be is totally my blame and
has not
do with them so that's the only reason
why I hesitate to like shout out credit
and stuff is I don't know if they want
credit but they did help and it meant a
lot to me anyway
so phase 2 is the newest phase of this
thing this is what I'm working on
currently this is like the current
development branch and you know what I'm
just gonna start going through these so
the games go up to ten you'll notice
that nine is missing some of them
weren't labeled because I decided not to
put the numbers in till later but nine
is on a different engine what's gonna
happen is I'm gonna delete all these
branches and clean this up after this
and then once I get it all cleaned up
I'm gonna actually make this private
repo public and I think it's due time
but I want to get rid of the mess that I
created and I don't want people confused
by this like what the heck is this what
branch am I supposed to you that I'm
gonna clean that all up after this video
so I just a part of it is just
documenting what happened and what's
going on so let's let's jump into it so
first I'm gonna just go ahead and switch
branches well I've got some stuff to
commit from whatever the heck I was
working on so I'm just literally gonna
name it hold commit all this and push it
because it's fine he doesn't you know I
know what I'm at alright so that's all
pushed up to github and up to date and
we're gonna go into manage branches and
go to the remotes and we're gonna find
summer originals
now masters pretty up-to-date I wonder
if I can get up on screen a well let's
do this I'm going to minimize this let's
get see if we can get up on screen
something about the branches here so
let's see here
we go two branches let's look at let's
look at stale okay it shows build one
and build two as sale tactic all these
games are stale and they're kind of in
order so this is actually perfect yeah
this is perfect
so yeah it was kind of this is how it
kind of all started okay from how this
really started another quick little
story is basically I was taking a
computer graphics class in college and
has one of my final projects I kind of
started what it was started beginning to
turn into more of a game engine than an
actual game and that was just out of
necessity I guess and that's kind of
what these eventually turned into I
graduated college I kept working on
stuff and build one and built two or
that and then and then all these schemes
so we're going to show you the games and
I guess not nine and ten I'm going to
I'm gonna have to show you nine and
unreal because it's and that doesn't
mean it's good I didn't know how to use
unreal I was just goofing around
basically trying to do something all
right so let's do this game one let's go
to build one I feel like I say let's do
this all the time like overhyping and
then just talking more okay so this is
on an old version it's probably not
gonna like that
I might have to go to my laptop tonight
because I know this works no no build
one doesn't work I tried it on my laptop
too and it didn't so I have something in
figured wrong an old version of
something I think it actually said there
but I'm not going to address this we owe
it's in high a uses a different version
of a simp okay that's maybe something we
can solve quickly I think a lot of these
too
neither DLL for it and I don't have it
uh do I want to mess with that right now
not really okay let's go on the build to
build to is a lot like build one there's
not gonna be a huge difference build one
might even look better because I think
it's just minor changes but I think can
build one I had the field of view a
little different and stuff like that so
build one whatever we're gonna forget
about that build two so this is the one
it's more worth showing off a little I
guess all right so here's what it looked
like uh how many how long ago let's look
at this nine months okay so it's been
nine months
that's not bad it feels like it's been
years honestly times been crawling for
this engine I know people usually say
time flies but I feel like I've been
working on this forever and I guess I
have nine months is a pretty long time
but it honestly feels to me like if I
didn't have track of time and just said
oh I don't know about two years ago you
know it feels like two years so I don't
know I guess it's just the way it is
when you're programming and you're very
critical this is still compiling don't
worry and once this launches we'll be
able to play the game and take a look
about it and see what it does I'll
explain explain it I'm probably not
gonna go through the code the code is
probably a mess so I don't even want to
get into that but if there's a lot of
you know I'll probably wait a week to
make this public or maybe two so there's
a like a lot of comments saying like I
want to see the code for this or that
I'll do it that's fine so that way these
branches won't be deleted immediately
after the video ok so here we are we're
in the game I made it fullscreen so I
had first-person controls working and
had the movement working worth a swd
standard waz - huh and I had a little
jump huh and it's a little wonky it's
actually it's not even going through a
function so just you go up and then you
fall down but it doesn't do it like in a
proper arc but once you're falling
here's the thing about the way that he
was doing the jump logic at this time
and I was
I'm writing it when you're falling you
you stop going forward so he just goes
straight down like fluff and it's it's
weird
well wait wait wait I think I have it so
if you're falling and you stop pressing
forward you go straight down huh which
is confusing huh and you can't restart
going forward if you're already falling
so that that's a mouthful but that was
like the logic I had and it ended up
being a little wonky because it's hard
to get on top of blocks now really this
game doesn't really have a beginning an
end it's basically just a bunch of
randomized blocks with textures and
lighting and light about your character
so as you walk through this giant mass
of random blocks with random textures
some of them I created from pictures
that I took like so like so yeah all
these little flower ones are stuff from
a hike and I just took a bunch of
pictures and these other ones that I
don't know some that's actually from a
tree I saw that other ones are just
random stuff I created her had and some
of them were grabbed off the internet so
I think this one was grabbed off the
internet this is just a little circle I
made in camp nothing you know there's a
lot of weird stuff this with water but
it didn't really you can tell I guess
like right there but it's on the blog
it's like what the heck is that
so yeah this and I apparently I got one
pixel off there so whoopsie
so yeah this was basically just a way
for me to stress test I wanted to see
how many blocks I could render I wanted
to test my randomize functions and I
wanted to test my lighting and just that
all the textures work and there's just a
bunch of cubes everything's a cube the
floor is a cube
your players a point so you got a camera
of course but your your a point so it
was like it checks the collision logic
with a single point for the player and
basically the goal is to get on top if
you can get it to the very top of the
blocks the highest one you win and
another weird thing as you can see I'm
walking on darkness the jump or the fall
logic doesn't update unless you press
jump so you can once you're up to a
level you can walk around in
where else to jump so it's kind of a
unique gameplay element that was
unintentional is a yeah you got to get
to the top but to make it a little
easier for you once you're just some
certain level you can walk around the
level at that level find something else
to jump on and then begin again and you
know you can kind of climb that way and
you get a little freedom oh let's try
this one for example
don't try to huh theoretically meet my
own game so this is pretty good actually
because I can jump right here and where
else can I go I guess I can go over here
huh and if I mess up any of these jumps
and remember the jump is wonky huh okay
that sent me a little below the plane
but now it was good and the colliding I
was using was just a a BB box collision
nothing special there look it up and
find tons info about that and I'm
getting close to the top now Oh No okay
the fall on the jump is very easy to
mess up see there's there's probably the
top right there is there anything higher
I don't see anything maybe that one is I
don't know this one looks a little
higher to me can we get it yes we did it
alright so we're now on top of this
little world of our build to game and we
have in theory one we can go walk around
on the top if we want in this level so
yeah this was really not truly game this
was just a big stress test randomization
of function to place blocks and textures
and test out the collision of the
jumping and it was it was a good fun
build
good times and I wasn't pretty happy
with how the lighting was looking at
this time there's no shadows or anything
as you can tell okay well that's it for
build 2 let's get out of here
so that was 9 months ago whether that
was last worked on and what you're gonna
see is that's probably gonna be one of
the most impressive looking ones and the
reason why is as we started doing these
little game builds we I was I say we but
it was really me I imposed a one-week
time to work on them in that time often
went into figuring out things on the
engine and trying to add features and
yeah I guess at at the time I
I don't know we'll see we'll see maybe
they're not as bad as I think honestly I
I don't remember but I feel like they're
pretty bad okay so then we go to tactics
now be warned I don't think this works
at all so let's just see what it is
let's go to tactics this was the first
game the first week we tried to make a
game and the goal here I'll talk about
the goal but you won't see it reflected
in any gameplay or anything the goal was
to make like a little Final Fantasy
Tactics type move around game where you
could have a little battle and I don't
think we I don't think I really got it
to where I wanted now as you saw one
build - there was no skybox I started
trying to implement a skybox later so we
might see a little of that yeah we might
see some iterations of that so I'm
actually really excited to do this video
and and keep going with it this is
probably one of the first vlogs that I
was kind of excited about when I thought
about doing this the others I kind of
just did them because I felt like I
needed to do something I don't know if
you guys ever feel like that just like I
got to do something one needs done okay
let's do that and rest assured it is
compiling while it's compiling let's go
look at these branches again so just to
fill the time looks like our next one is
rats calves an endless runner
I think endless runner was the first one
that kind of worked and these X's I
don't know what these X's mean okay the
game's launching this is tactics okay
okay here we go
I remember this is all coming back we
tried a lot of different things and I
ended up kind of doing a randomized
height map so this was intended to be
the little map that your little grid
characters would sit on not you could
have it at different levels for you know
high processing for whatever you're
doing if you're shooting arrows or
something or you're taking and the
collision still in here on the camera
which is sort of weird because it's no
bounce intended I never got I basically
didn't get around to doing anything with
little placing little guys on the map
cuz I was figuring out stuff and so this
is what tagged
looking like we the start of what would
be a grid map all right let's get out of
here
that's so you were warned it's not gonna
work let's take a look at rats calves I
don't remember what happened here to be
perfectly honest I am this is gonna be a
total surprise for me I don't think it
was anything functional so we'll see
what it looks like
good old rats calves we've checked it
out now let's hit build that's one of
the great things about github and visual
studios you can just it's this easy to
switch between builds well obviously
build one wasn't working so I might as
well delete that to be honest but I'm
gonna keep it for now maybe I'll dig
into it you know I say that but it's
like I have a million other things to do
I'm not gonna dig into an old branch
what am I kiddin myself alright so this
one's getting deleted we'll do it live
delete from remote it's gone
type in passkey I'm gonna do this
off-screen I don't know if it'll even
matter it's not like you can see but
type type type
alright so build one is gone and that's
perfect because it was totally useless
these animation attempts were they were
garbage ok we are compiling so we're not
totally we are compiling rats cab right
now but while that's going these
animation attempts I'll probably delete
these too I have no idea what's going on
anymore I was basically just playing
around with trying to animate models and
I didn't get it quite working ever -
well I got it some basic versions of it
working but I had some issues with the
way I was doing my logic and trying to
add in bones so this is rats cave this
isn't actually anything about rats cabin
but as you can see I got the skybox
working and so that was nice and there's
kind of a low quality I think I think
this bottom square texture is rotated
wrong maybe yeah it is it needs to be
right there so that's interesting but
yeah there is a skybox and you can move
endlessly towards it but it is literally
a box if you see in the center of the
screen there you can sort of see a
corner but it's set to render in a way
where you can never actually go through
it I don't think anyway I don't remember
no it looks like it's going bigger I
at this time we didn't have something
about the view figured out about it see
you it looks like you moved towards the
skybox but so here I kind of managed to
make a weird sphere and it rendered
wrong I think I had the element indices
wrong
looks like I've disabled the jump in
this build so this is rasgap there's
really nothing there's an original grid
I think I programmed in some some plain
building and I don't know what else
happened but it didn't get very far
there's no rat scavenging but I was kind
of playing around with getting different
models loading in and just play
something I don't know I don't know I
obviously didn't finish this there's no
rat there's no scavenging it's not rats
cap but hey maybe one day let's go to
the next one these are really
embarrassing the show actually but you
know I don't care screw it
it needs needs to be and it needs to be
dealt with in like my life needs to move
on endless-runner now this one I
remember was pretty fun I'm curious to
see what it looks like I don't don't
expect anything great though just before
warrant but this was about the point
where we started getting involved in
some physics and the physics aren't in
this build but I remember that my friend
Eric had kind of sorted out the jump
problem and had pushed that as a
solution but there was some issue with
it going I don't remember exactly so
it's not in this build here it was doing
something else weird like it was doing
something like slingshot and you across
the map at some point so I didn't want
to put that in the one that was like the
done one but it was a lot better
I remember visually in the work he had
done so this is compiling right is it
yeah I think it is endless-runner
I believe this is a first-person
endless-runner but these aren't all
first-person
all right well it is compiling I'm just
some silence here I don't know what else
to talk about you know I really don't
want to edit this video I don't want to
have to edit so I'm gonna keep talking
so it's more entertaining and people
don't just leave all the time but we got
more to go through this is gonna be
interesting we're gonna see all of these
so maybe if you don't have time to view
all the videos and come back later okay
here we go endless-runner let's make it
fullscreen alright so I have a different
skybox loaded up is it aligned properly
actually looks decent it's a little
pixelated and it doesn't do anything
it's just a big cube map but here's
endless-runner and I remember this now
okay so you start on the edge of a
platform like over a canyon and there's
nothing to do but run forward so you run
forward it's got a little footstep
sounds and one loud footstep I don't
know why these footsteps are actually
yeah all these sound effects I recorded
I think except for the jump one huh no
that's from I don't remember where this
from that's not mine huh that's someone
else's I almost don't remember where it
came from but these footsteps are my
recordings I think they're with my foot
on pavement alright so if you run you
can run with holding shift still got the
gold for the person controls sort of now
I set the camera a little higher you
notice I'm your player is not right next
to the blocks like it was in the
previous version so I figured out to
raise the camera so it doesn't look so
weird like you're looking from someone's
shoes or something yeah we can just keep
running and this is literally the game
you literally just endlessly run so I
guess it's a complete game right it it
is what it tighten says I don't remember
there's an end or not I totally forget
I'm gonna keep running say we can get to
the end and the footsteps do show off on
you're jumping I think there's like an
on-ground flag I don't know how long
this goes maybe I did make it unless my
also I feel like I had some kind of calf
when I was programming it because there
was something I didn't want to sort out
to truly make it endless so I just made
it seem endless cuz you get so bored
that you'll give up and just think it's
in listen alright let's go to the next
game I think it's just really long you
will eventually get there though I
remember some points of building this
you could run through the skybox I don't
think that happens is this the end it's
the end yeah we did have okay so the sky
back box is fixed in this one you can't
actually run through it I think in that
other built rat's cab or whatever you
could actually run through the sky box
if you kept going and we got that sorted
out before this one there's the end
that's theoretical end can we jump off
yeah we can actually the fall logics all
there and I think it has a proper
velocity that those went out of render
distance so there is a render distance
but now that we're just endlessly
falling you can't really tell I think I
might have it logged no I don't have it
logged okay well let's get out of that
and now we're on to side scroller
fighter this one was fun I actually
started a job when I started working on
this so I remember I'm having memories
of that week that's interesting it's
really interesting that okay let's check
it out that a code branch will bring
back memories of a very specific week of
your life because I remember sitting in
my little Airbnb room just working on
this thing all week as soon as I would
get off work I would go to my place you
know I would eat or something and then I
go to my place and I would just like
code all night and it was it's
interesting to just bring back all those
memories I even remember the places I
ate and stuff it's mostly Taco Bell all
right so here we are we're compiling
side scroller fighter yeah side scroller
fighter so the intent of this was like I
don't know an old arcade style game
where you just fight from the side and I
didn't have a whole lot of time to work
on this so the first I remember this
game because I compiled this one
recently to show someone I started
getting some interactions with the
objects working so
that was kind of the the big milestone
for me is collision detection along with
some some movement of objects and it was
about this point that also I kind of
lost my partner-in-crime
on and helped because I was away and we
couldn't communicate as well alright so
you get a little guy these are just
stupid things I drew in [ __ ] in like two
seconds can you get a sword and these
enemies come out here they got three hit
points I believe so you gotta hit him
three times and the attack is just a
left click and when you attack it just
makes this object appear that's a little
sword and I didn't obviously I didn't
have the Alpha sorted out least one are
actually supposed to be 3d models so
these are like placeholders and jump
just rise it makes you raise up in the
air so this is like the same level as
the endless-runner just a camera set
aside and follows your character now so
I did get all that going let's make it
fullscreen
and yeah you basically just do that why
do you attack enemies when one dies
another one spawns up ahead so you can
kind of keep running toward and
attacking them and if you get hit it
bounces you back what okay that's the
audio is really loud and your guyses and
it's not for me if I'm gonna turn it
down I'm sorry sorry I blew it out
anybody save your drums there my bad
alright so yeah that's all this is I
don't I think this goes about the same
length as an endless-runner
the next step here was I was gonna get
some health bars and kind of a reset
screen because you do die him but it
doesn't actually do anything the game
like doesn't process that so I just ran
out of time I think but I remember
getting real excited about like making
things appear when you clicked and
colliding with things and checking their
collision so that was nice collision
collision that's completely different
alright so this was a very exciting one
to work on and I feel like it was kind
of a milestone for me cuz of all the new
stuff and yeah just bringing back that
week of working and I was working in
Dayton Ohio and this is about the timer
I remember was a week or two later
I was a tornado went through Dayton it's
crazy all right so let's go to the next
one and the rest of these I was also
working full time so I don't remember
getting a ton of time to work on these
but I'll see what I think it was just
like a couple weekend days of peace to
work on these when it was supposed to be
a full week so let's take a look let's
see see what these are so battle royale
is the next one and this one's not
complete I don't even think this is a
thing I don't even think this is
playable I think there's nothing here to
be honest so don't have any expectation
but the intention was to get a couple
players I think I was gonna do it with
just a few AI bots but yeah it was
supposed to be some sort of little
replica and a site of a battle royale I
don't remember really getting anything
done I remember wanting to do a mesh
world with different heights and just
basically somehow get a little server up
where another person can connect and it
would the server would keep track of the
positions and like maybe your main
damage object but I ran into some issues
with the server stuff and it took a long
time so I don't think I did learn a lot
about the server side of stuff but I
don't think I got it functional yeah it
crashes here it just straight up crashes
OH on a health bar render I was trying
to get health bars going to so I don't
know why exactly I don't know why this
ended up pushed if it was a broken
branch so we're just gonna skip that one
for now and we'll say that there's
nothing really to show but I did i do
remember learning a lot I really dug
into a lot of networking stuff and how
to like set up a little local server and
build it yourself
so it was a very it was very good week
actually as far as that but I just
didn't mess with this engine much
because I was doing a lot of research I
think I made a side branch of this
called like ancient archers server or
something and it's private I believe but
it's not functional currently I need to
come back to that and one day I would
like to get it functional but it was
getting closer and I was learning a lot
so let's go to MMO I think this one was
kind of cool I remember working with a
friend on this my friend Erica and
he got a few moving things going so that
was kind of cool and I don't know what
else or honestly just gonna have to take
a look I don't remember what else
happened here I think there's a some
kind of little world or something no it
looks like it's compiling so as you can
probably tell just by how much stuff I
have to talk about there's a lot of
stuff to think about
when you're making a game engine we
didn't even ever really get to things
like particles and our physics and
collision we're never very good so I
understand that it's kind of you know or
I guess it's important to understand
that some of these things you just kind
of get working if you want to show
something and then later you can improve
it but I remember I also remember as I
was going through these branches I was
often changing the layout of like the
files which is not a good idea because I
just wasn't happy with it and I was
getting lost in code and I was like okay
and the engine files need to go here so
some of these branches I was rather than
working on the game I was spending a lot
of time thinking about features how to
add them what to add and here we go
we're in so this was a it was a branch
called MMO and I was kind of working on
a little world I remember I wanted to
play our icon so I ended up just putting
this block here and now rather than the
player being a point like it wasn't some
earlier versions the player is a block
so it collides like a block and all that
but you know I was just kind of a weird
thing I just we basically just added
some various parts we were gonna add
like more of a closed off world rather
than the sky that's you know we never
really got to that and that way you'd be
like kind of look like you're in a world
or feel like you're in a world but it
feels like you're in like on an old
space station or something I don't know
and here's yeah here's one moving thing
that you have to get past and then
there's like I don't know it's just a
little maze was just a layout of
rectangular blocks it's really nothing
special but it was kind of fun to be
like alright let's play around with
and really that's it it was just moving
about a world I think most of this time
I was kind of messing with a lot of the
engined
code structure and I remember not being
happy with the sounds so I turned them
off as you can hear there's no jump
sound or no walk sound so that happened
all right let's go to the next one plant
growing and this one the goal was to get
a just like some little game where you
grow plants and I don't know what
happened I think it turned into
minecraft sort of thing I may have made
a video on it at one point because I was
like it's cool right you know let's
check it out
it's compiling yeah it's compiled away
we'll be there in a second see what else
can I talk about why it's compiling look
at these branches again we're all the
way up to plant growing and if we've
refreshed this build one should be gone
no because I deleted it yep there's
build to the oldest stale branch
and we've only got one more to show I
might show this I don't know what this
is this isn't a game or anything but if
it's a working branch I'll show it I
want to show kind of where it left off
might as well okay whoa okay I got him
the new skybox I think this I chose the
skybox cuz it's a higher res it's the
one from learn OpenGL and I was just
tired of seeing that low res skybox I
think full screen but as you can see
there's a little block in front of us
right in the center of the screen and
that's intended to be the detection
block so when you click it if it
overlaps with another block it does
something to that block there you go and
in this one it removes it and apparently
it extends out I think it's actually a
vector so it's like it has a bunch of
checkpoints all the way up to that block
and maybe even beyond it a little it
seems like beyond a because I'm clicking
stuff beyond it but here you can see
we're just kind of clicking squares like
we're mining them or something and I can
do that below us too and you can
actually dig way down in the world I'll
do that in a second but there's also
this little section this is somewhat
kind of left here to test with hope and
you can uh you can grab these so the
intention here was like I wanted to get
internet more interaction with blocks
going there I didn't ever get to the
plant because well I don't remember why
exactly but it basically just wasn't
working out everything I was trying and
I and I had at some point some some
things that grew but I wasn't happy with
it so I deleted it and I didn't end up
in this version so this is really just
like kind of a block game I think you
right click yeah if you right-click you
can place a block but it was gonna be
like for placing plants and I was just
like into that code I was still working
full time too so I think this was a we
ended up being kind of a weekend thing
of just messing with code and there's
the there's the block and you can do you
can collide with these blocks no you
can't nevermind later I added that but
you can kind of pseudo build things I
don't know it's let's be honest it's
it's not very good and there's no
lighting at the character right now so
as you get close to
you see darkness because the lights just
a directional light pointing
approximately in the direction I'm
looking I think so on this side of locs
it's all dark and that's kind of weird
wait can you turn on the light maybe I
had a toggle I don't remember
oh yeah you can the one key turns on
your light yeah okay so that was
something I was messing with too totally
light I mean it's not that hard really
once you have light you can just talk
one off do it all in the code but as you
can see you can kind of like mine down
into the ground and there's some
different layers
I remember setting up all these layers
and I'm just gonna mine down really deep
oh and eventually you get to lava and
after the lava you fall through the
world so that's that's basically the
whole thing so that there was plant
growing as you can see it wasn't plant
growing at all but more like just
messing around with blocks next one
space shooter I don't remember what
happened with this I think we abandoned
it unfortunately let me take a look some
I was trying really hard to get like
something working and I was stuck at the
time and it it was a little too rough I
remember it's stressing out on this one
like I'm not gonna have anything to show
this isn't going very well and my friend
was so nice helping me out he like made
some really sweet little 2d textures of
spaceships and I was really excited to
use them and I don't remember if I ever
got to use them so we'll see I guess
what this looks like and maybe I have
them stowed away somewhere and I can do
him the honour of actually using the
textures he spent time on because yeah
there were much better than my textures
and that was cool well
compiling the old space shooter let's
see what happens I think we might have
ended up trying unity for this for a
while and ran out of time and just
didn't have anything to show okay okay
here it is this is not this is
essentially nothing I basically have a
top-down camera that moves and I was
gonna have like little spaceships and
you know you go through a level and
fight stuff and shoot and you know all
the all the usual top-down shooter
things but it ended up being just this
yeah I think we essentially ran out of
time if I remember correctly and there's
just not you can't really do much you
can move around like a top-down camera
so that's all it looks like but you know
we were working on we were working on it
alright so let's go to the next one
I'm actually gonna see that was eight
there is no nine and that's that's true
so the actually the ninth one was called
Museum and it was just basically
supposed to be like exploring a museum
turn on on and off lights around the
place and just kind of messing with how
many effects we could do so I'm gonna
show you that and unreal I hope I still
actually have it I'm not I'm sure I do
see let's I think it's on this version
so let's launch the old version of the
engine here and I'll show you what it
looked like I you know I was gonna do in
my engine but I was kind of getting fed
up with things and I was having a tough
time so I think I just needed to step
away and I was like alright let's let's
do this one and unreal I just want an
editor where I can place blocks and an
interface you know and you know I didn't
really have I don't really have any
scripting for this engine yet but I am
actually working on that currently all
right here's museum let's open it oh I
need 4.22 okay let's see so what I need
to do here is just relaunch Unreal in
launch 4.22 here this should work looks
like they're on 4.23 now so any of you
out there that might be watching what
engine you
think is best unreal unity I like them
both but I don't use them much because I
don't know I just have I have this weird
weird passion for liking to work on
things under the hood and I don't I
don't understand it myself but I would
rather build a game engine then use
somebody else's and I don't know why and
I think about it and ask myself why I
don't have a good answer other than I
just I just like it it's it's a it's
such a monumental stressful task and I
guess I like that sort of thing I like I
like trying to beat impossible odds and
stuff like that I don't it's just part
of my personality I guess alright so
here we go I'm gonna hit play and just
gonna see where I left off okay so it's
just the first person guy and I made a
little building and I put some lights in
it and I think I was testing out making
things in blender and importing them and
that's basically all I did I put him in
a little glass things lined up
everything that's a weird thing I made
in blender but the cool thing to me was
I was like you just import objects and
they all just work and I was like I mean
buying to do that there's a little light
I'm made to try to be like an alarm
light thing or something I don't know
but it never really got finished as you
can see I just lined up everything it
made it look like a little room put a
little light at the top and hey it's
unreal that's uh that's what the ninth
one was so yeah I guess I could have
done something like this in my engine
without too much trouble but I didn't
have object loading objects loading from
blender at the time in my engine and it
does now support that so you can just
make whatever you want in blender MI or
whatever and import it and it's no big
deal
but yeah unreal it's obviously not too
hard to do that so let's get out of here
that was it and ten ten never happened
ten was supposed to be a game called
acid frog and I don't think it ever
happened there was no branch that maybe
I had a local branch at one point but I
don't think I ever pushed it because I
don't think I ended up doing any work I
was another busy week at work so let's
look at some of these animation attempts
and just see and to see what they are I
think three might be the one that
actually does something
I don't know what this is Oh this was
the oldest one let's check this one out
this was the one that was actually on
the list model animations so this was
the next stale branch after space
shooter that's on this ancient archer
okay we have we don't need to run real
anymore all right so back to this model
animations let's just hit play I don't
know what's gonna happen here I have no
clue what's gonna happen here
it might even crash it might not work at
all
so we'll see I remember oh yeah on one
of these one of these weeks I spent like
way too long messing with glyphs and
loading in glyphs and ultimately I think
I had something wrong in the shader so
it didn't work anyway and it was such a
stressful week to just be like I've just
been messing with this all all week and
when I finally try it just doesn't work
I was stressed it was annoying but I
think I could figure it out now if I
went back to it but that's a lot of how
coding is I mean there's a lot of
there's a lot of like really popular
YouTube channels with really smart and
good coders at the helm of them and they
can show you stuff a really quick that's
just like whoa but for me I'm not at
that level yet I hope to be someday but
you know that's that's something that
you can't really just do you have to
kind of work towards and earn it this is
compiling so maybe one day I'll be there
but right now yeah I still feel like I'm
learning a lot of stuff so it's cool on
you know some days things will click new
things will click and I'll be like
alright cool now I can I can do all this
so I guess that's kind of part of my
drive to make an engine is I just want
to learn all of this stuff and I feel
like it's the best way to just dive in
and really have no trying to think the
right way to word this I want to say no
sympathy yeah it is kind of like a no
sympathy because it is brutal to try to
take on all this but for some reason
like that yeah he just you can't do much
alright this was a branch
I remember this this is just like a
little square world to run around in and
yeah there's some model loading here and
that's
so I think done blender on the rest of
these were not so this is just like a
low arena with a little wooden ledge
basically I don't know what it was just
a test it was just a big test and I
think we can load in different worlds if
I press 1 2 & 3 so let's try it one -
yeah - here we go here's some weird
model that loads in with a lava texture
for some reason so this was also a part
of that world from plant growing it's
just a block that kind of represents
layers of earth and just kind of stayed
in because I thought it was cool and
here's another switch so I was also at
this point
testing out switching between different
sets of things to render and these were
supposed to animate and obviously they
don't so there were some weird errors
but being able to switch between sets of
things a render was kind of cool but I
also noticed as I was doing this any
time I switch levels
it doesn't free the old memory so I
noticed a big problem here when I was
doing this I'm like oh I am just
continually pushing things to something
or I don't know so watch now I'll go
back to this and look now up to like 800
so eventually this would run out of
memory and crash because something's I
got some garbage code in there but
that's not a big deal that doesn't
happen anymore
in the new system so that was model
animations let's go to animations
attempts free here I don't know what
this is but out of these three I think
this was the one that actually might
compile but these are going to be gone I
will be getting rid of these branches of
code because they serve no purpose for
me I'm not going to go back and
reference them or anything like that
because what up from what I remember the
animation code is broken and there's no
sense of referencing broken code so I
kind of need to start from scratch and
dig in that way I don't really want to
fix my broken code because chances are
it's like one or two little things
somewhere and that's so that's so hard
to fix when it's just you can look at a
wall of text and be like alright find
the variable that's just in the wrong
place that's that can be so challenging
especially when it's you don't know
where it's at it could be anywhere so I
was trying to get all the the
referencing of the bones and the model
translations right and for some reason
it just wasn't working
and it was a it was it was frustrating I
feel like if I gave it another another
took another crack at it I could
probably get it within a few days but
I'm just sort of taking a break from the
whole animation pipeline and I will
revisit it we'll get it working just
like I will with the network code and
improving all the other things just
something that's going to be iterated
over time this is compiling this might
be very similar to model animations
because I don't think I did a whole lot
of different stuff I think I was just
testing different variants of working
with the bones I think all right okay
there's like nothing here there's
literally nothing rendering I don't know
what's going on with this branch but
there's obviously nothing rendering okay
so let's go what is this I want to look
at this so this is something I kind of
started more recently I was gonna make a
game about like a swamp monster called
the swamp King there's a little more to
it than that but I don't want to give
away the whole story or the inspiration
yet but I don't think there's actually
anything here I meant you might have
seen it in unreal when I launched it I
was just messing about there's no real
there's no real game here but one day
one day I think I was working on this
and I was unhappy with the structure of
the engine and I just was like screw it
I'm starting over
so that's when phase 2 phase 2 was after
whole swamp ink ranch and this is a
giant rework this is nothing like the
old version structurally it's a whole
it's a whole different thing so you know
hairless I thought it was building at my
building yeah building I just don't see
the little output thing down here for
some reason that maybe I clicked it off
accidentally but it is compiling it is
trying so we'll give it a second it's
going right down there and we'll see
what happens and then after this I'll
switch to the latest branch I'm gonna
click it and I'll talk a little about it
and then I'm gonna end of it in the
video so bear with me for just a couple
more minutes and I appreciate you guys
hanging in for this long if you're here
and just checking out all this stuff
with me do let me know if you want to
see in this code and let me know soon
it's like you notice this videos been up
for like a month
and you say hey I want to see the code
I'm just gonna say it's gonna be gone I
don't expect it to be there because I do
want to make this public and I do want
to clean all that up first all right but
maybe I still could anyway to some
extent I might get a quick browse
through of the code on one last video
before I delete it and maybe if people
care at all because personally I don't I
don't care I don't want this code
anymore I remember writing it I can do
better now you know I don't know what
this is this is this is the swamp Kings
state right now it's just a bunch of
balls that don't read render correctly
and a red screen oh yeah I didn't I
didn't really get anywhere with that
it's not a thing so let's go to the
latest one I'll kind of show you where I
left off and what I'm working on the
start here switch to it and why play
so he immediately you'll notice I
started changing the structure I talked
about this in previous video but I'm
gonna assume that not everyone's seen it
so there's a there's engine files and
these are all like the backend code
these should all interact with each
other and be usable through a script but
the user shouldn't be able to like
directly edit anything in here and by
user I mean like person that's using the
game engine to create a game so within
tests is like okay maybe some examples
of what a developer would want to do to
run their game and the way this is
achieved for now I'm sure there's a
better way to do it's just what came to
mind here I'll show you in a sec all
right so here's something and there's a
few things I remember when I left off I
was working on getting cel-shading
working cell shading it's not working
but obviously I got some things moving
around rotating and moving with Delta
time and once the cell shading is
working I can I can demo these further
so I'm working a lot on the model code
more than anything these days and just
trying to I get that is squared away as
I can and support as much stuff that it
can and you know there's a lot of work
to do I don't have the sky box on right
now so it's just just a green background
so this is this is current iteration
this is where we're at and it's got a
full-screen hotkey which blinks out my
recording screen for a minute apparently
so that wasn't in the previous one I
took an off full-screen there and we'll
just there we go all right so yeah this
is where his what I'm working on
currently it's really a whole different
structure altogether so yeah so I build
up these engine files of try to try to
make a little thing run some tests I
think I'm mainly using this these are
all test files and model just runs
whatever you want to run of them and
it's a very straightforward test system
I thought about using catch two or
something but that doesn't seem
necessary I probably will later and yeah
here's the function so one of the cool
things about this that I just decided to
do and it seems to be working out okay
we'll see how long it
continues for let me do a collapse all
function here press buttons here we go
scroll up okay so this is a fun one
function that does a bunch of stuff
stress engine function so yeah so I'm
supposed to stress the engine I got a
whole bunch of models I'm a blender and
I've got some fly speed stuff too for
the camera controls and I make a bunch
of functions so this right here is a
static function that I'm making here so
it can be used and I show pitch and you
know yeah there's a bunch of stuff
custom key input so basically I'll go to
the engine and just show you this what
you do when you want to get your engine
going is you instantiate the engine then
you add all this stuff you want to set
up your keys your mouse and your scroll
and the reason you set them is because
you want to have access to them from
whatever file you're working in and
they're not hidden within the engine but
the engine needs them so that it can
update them and then you also add
functions to any of these parts of the
main loop so the main loops kind of
handled for you all you got to do is add
functions to well there's the on began
that runs once there's the on Delta
update that will take a delta time and
you can do what you want with that
there's the on render where you should
basically render what you need to render
and there's an update which is you know
stuff you want to process in your loop
but it doesn't rely on Delta time and
there's key handling that will update
your keys so you can take the you can
take whatever these keys are and and do
all your controls of that switch and
stuff and same with the scroll one mouse
so and then and then you basically run
the engine you don't have access to
these private ones Caesar so when you
run the engine it does begin and then it
starts a loop or does update render or
update and that's basically I put a
timer in there yeah so the main loop
looks a little like and this is probably
something you've seen before but when
you hit run run is what enters the main
loops this whole function right here and
there's the main loop so it does a few
things for the main loop is set checks
the key as a mouse and scroll or set
just a little task
you kind of need something that runs
begin function and if you look at any of
these they basically just go through a
loop of all the stuff you've added to
the engine as a developer so you can
kind of set those up how you want you
can set up to begin the update or render
and the update how you want and if
you're doing it with all all within a
file and you can have like static
variables to to stay in place so that
you can use them in your lambdas and
those will work for your engine and you
can essentially build a game by just
scripting in C++ now I've thought about
making some sort of actual scripting
functionality support so that you could
do it in like Lua or something and I
might add that later but for right for
now you basically script in C++ and it
seems a little weird but I personally
like it
hi find it to be nice so I can just
basically build up a file instantiate an
engine and do whatever I want with my
engine and then I just run that in my
main like like so and it does everything
so I could make an entire game like that
and it would be interesting to see how
it did on memory but as you can see with
this test of adding these objects and
processing them all this only uses 67
megabytes and most of that is the GL FW
stuff so I'm probably only using like
one or two megabytes and in all that
stress code and that's moving placing
and loading and textures I've got more
textures load so as it grows it will
obviously get bigger but I'm pretty
happy with it being how it is so far
with using only 67 that might be a lot
to some people but comparing to my old
versions where I was using like 300 400
megabytes somehow I don't even know how
this feels pretty good and it's
obviously using like no CPU power there
you know you can see and yeah have a
little C out here I need to get rid of
those but there's a lot of testing going
on all right so that's the engine that's
where it's at now thank you so much for
watching I hope you guys all have a
great holiday I don't know what time of
the year to be watching this but it's
about to be Christmas and I don't know
20 to 20 days 18 days so most people are
kind of in that mode around here but you
could also be watching for somewhere
else I have no controller idea but I
appreciate anyone
from wherever you are that's into this
coding stuff as much as I am it's such a
cool fun thing to do I will be
continuing this project this vlog I'm
trying to get back to my screen
why does not letting me I think it
crashed oh yeah I'm really looking
forward to continuing this and
continuing to work on all this and you
know if you want to see more you want to
see how this goes consider hitting that
subscribe button if you appreciate these
sort of videos and want to show your
support your your welcome to that via
comment via an upvote via checking out
my patreon or my other stuff whatever
you want to do that's cool
alright well keep coding guys and I will
see you in the next video over and out
this has been Matt from code tech and
tutorials I'll see you guys in the next
video